win Fitness as a product and service was
invented in my mind 1980 obesity has
doubled since 1980. the health club
industry has upper right corner upper
right corner year over year 30 billion
dollar industry today what is not
working here
Fitness is working
Fitness when you study and in a lab
you've studied it in your body
I have to it works Fitness is not broken
Fitness is good
what I have discovered is that our
relationship to Fitness is broken and
there is so much shame in that
relationship copying skips understanding
and movement is an exercise of
exercising body wisdom of learning about
your body that's why I love it now I
have my attachment to that versus it
being a chore shame I'm not good enough
my injury is something I should push
away instead of work with